My name is Alfonso Aguirre Rodriguez also known as Mithy and I play support for G2 Esports.
I knew I could be good at whatever game I played so
I just wanted to become pro at the next upcoming esport
and I think I started like officially
started probably back towards the
end of season two. Took me like,
season 3 this when I became a pro. Look at that, Lemondogs forced to run here
as they lose Dexter, Araneae gets popped in the air. Mithy manages to pick up that kill.
Lemondogs was a turning
point for me because I was actually now
playing against all the people that I
idolized for a whole year and it was fun
I learned a lot. I was really like pressuring myself to be good
and always perform well. I got the Worlds
and I realized, I actually,
the first time I like smashed into a wall and was like fuck I'm bad you know and that
was kind of like what I was looking for
and searching for when I smashed into
that wall at Worlds I really got a lot
of motivation and I was like oh my god
like I can be so much better.
I had my time out for toxicity and
everything, but during all that time I
was actually like improving myself as a
player and I think I learned a lot even
though I was in challenger scene and I
got a lot out of it so I knew,
especially on my time out I also had
time to think and I think I coached a group for
like two weeks or something.
It wasn't until I joined Origen where I,
finally I would say match the players
that were not really egoed or biased or like, narrow-minded and actually just
made me open my mind to different ways
of looking at the game especially
Amazing, he would always like say
something that I wouldn't really
understand. After I looked back at it for a
few times and looked at it closely, it made
sense to me and would make me improve as a player.
Origen will place first in Group D after taking down KT Rolster. And with the crowd behind them, Origen go undefeated.
Everyone had their way of talking to
everyone else. Everyone had their own
personalities. Everyone had like, their
small roles within the team and
no one really tried to do more than
their roles because everyone was like
stuck in the same way of viewing the
game and the same way of playing it.
I felt that even if I joined a challenger
team I would improve more as a player
than if I stayed in OG.
We just didn't have the, probably
coaching staff I can blame it on
that kinda like help us like view things
differently and talk to each other in a
different way and just open our minds to
different situations.
I had to make a decision. It was not easy and I stated some of the reasons why I made that decision
in like a public Facebook post. Before I
made the decision I already accepted
what the consequences of that decision
would be.
Apart from the whole winning swap, it
was the only thing that really could
take us both and was willing to like
invest on taking us both so that's kind
of how it went. I wanted to play with
Zven, Zven wanted to play with me and
there was never really a downhill slope
with him so I didn't really see why I
wouldn't keep playing with him if I would
just like be constantly learning like I
had been for a whole year and a half
before that. I thought it was a safe bet
to join G2 because four out five
players were already going to click for
sure and then there was Kikis and
Expect. I would say that our
challenge for this split was getting us four to connect with Expect and with Kikis.
Will it be enough, yes it will.
Trashy, another lamb to the
slaughter. Stand united is gonna finish
the channel. Mithy saves everyone!
To say now oh my god things are really going good, we're first and things are great
everyone is working hard, we don't have
issues. But there's going to be a time
where we're going to have issues because
that's just how it works and it's about
how we confront those issues and
work towards them and stay as
a group and just understand them. Things
can go wrong at some point but right
now things are going great so I'm in a
very happy situation.
Welcome to the G2 era! They are your summer split champions.
It was just a dream come true. It
wasn't really something I expected.
This year I'd say a realistic goal would be to try to make it out of groups, but I
think that if we take this whole going
to Worlds thing and treat it as
an experience and just make our
goal like maybe making out of groups
maybe not, just like with OG but really
like trying to learn as much as we can
from this experience. I think we can
really put up a very very good performance.